depuis ses débuts à l'âge de 19 ans elle
a travaillé sur tous les continents avec
les plus grands metteurs en scène d'hier
d'aujourd'hui et sans doute de demain
depuis otto preminger a mis en scène
love en passant par chabrol chi minh hoa
ne que bellocchio récompensé aux golden
globes aux césars à cannes deux fois à
venise deux fois à berlin
j'en passe et des pires elle a été
présidente du jury de ce festival de
cannes en 2009 et elle présente cette
année en compétition le film de
l'américain a ra sac francky où elle
joue une actrice française figurez vous
elle est ce soir mon invité temps can
2019 bonsoir il a fallu faire merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous quelle
question est-ce que ça pose de jouer une
actrice je joue un personnage d'actrice
mais ça pose beaucoup plus de questions
à ceux qui voient le film que ceux qui
le font vous dites ça chaque fois non
mais c'est vrai moi ça m'a posé aucune
question mais c'est révélateur en même
temps il est question de faire pause
parce que ça a dit que au fond les gens
peut-être se font une représentation
assez stéréotypé de l'actrice alors
voilà ça ça les surprend ça les étonne
et c'est la première fois je crois qu'on
a cherché dans votre filmographie mais
lâche pas vraiment sous votre contrôle
que vous jouez lectrice de cinéma vous
avez été une actrice de théâtre dans
l'histoire de pira de marco ferreri
votre personnage de francky et même
comme vous une célèbre actrice française
du coup forcément on y pense en tant que
spectateur et ce qu'isabelle huppert
pourrait être en train de devenir un
personnage de fiction ça je ne sais pas
je n'ai pas la réponse à cette question
mais le fait que ça soit une célèbre
actrice française aussi ça ajoute à la
ca dramatise aussi le propos vous
oubliez de faire vous n'avez pas encore
dit que c'était qu'on célèbre actrice
française qui allait mourir bientôt
personnel maîtrisant française serait
plus dramatique que l'actrice américaine
l'actrice chinoise de l'actrice actrice
française mais avec une carrière un
petit peu internationale quand même il a
pensé à tout et oui un peu comme moi
comme certaine elle vous ressemble pas
du tout il aime beaucoup que les acteurs
ressemblent à eux mêmes dans ses films à
hérat sax à un point dieu sait si j'aime
me rapprocher le plus possible de moi
même quand je fais n'importe quel film
mais alors celui là encore plus parce
qu'il veut
il veut qu'on s'appuie sur aucune des
des petites baies qui vaut des petites
scories sur lesquels on se repose la
plupart du temps joué à rosser quand
même un peu l'assaisonner de plein de
petits détails de plein de petites
choses
lui il veut rien c'est très surprenant
ça m'a beaucoup intéressé je veux dire
par là que parfois vous êtes surprise ou
bien vouloir essayer quelques idées bien
oui oui mais parce qu'elles servent le
personnage parce qu'elles sont elles
font partie du ton du film par exemple
je pense par exemple à l'ironie ou
second degré mais vous avez beaucoup
j'en ai beaucoup
mais si j'en ai beaucoup c'est aussi
parce qu'elles correspondent au ton du
film suit vous tournez avec paul
verhoven ya que l'ironie du second degré
sinon on peut pas faire ça sent qu'il ya
de toute façon alors là il y avait des
scènes qui ne pouvait vous emmener vers
sa élevé ne voulais pas de ça et là où
l'effort c'est que les scènes étaient
quand même drôle mais vous n'allez
surtout pas qu'on aille au devant de
cette drôlerie et c'est un peu le cas
pour tous les sentiments qu'ils
expriment dans le film le film et est
tragique mais pas mélodramatique
le film est drôle mais jamais ironique
voilà et ça ils manient ça avec une
subtilité est un art de dosage à ses
soins il est beaucoup question dans le
film derrière la façade de vulnérabilité
c'est ce que je trouve assez magnifique
moi personnellement d'antan dans ce film
comment est ce qu'on l'a fait surgir les
élus par la vulnérabilité parfois ça
passe c'est la vulnérabilité crs axe qui
équipe qui me la propose aussi par la
manière voilà donc il déroule son
histoire par l'écriture par l'écriture
quand je tournais le film ça m'a
vraiment traversé l'esprit mais par
contre quand je les ai vus et peintes
ans que j'entends parler du film
il m'est apparu clairement que c'est un
personnage de tragédie et que le film
emprunte à la tragédie je trouve sur la
violence de la lumière l'affluence delà
de la du tragique dans la nature il ya
du tragique dans la dent là quelque
chose d'irrémédiable dans le dans le
destin il ya tous et à toutes ces forces
là qui sont au travail dans le film donc
il ya une très grande force mais n'y a
pas de faiblesse mais ça n'empêche pas
la fragilité puisque la flemme baisse et
la fragilité c'est pas la même chose qui
m'intéresse c'est que ça vous échapper
pour dernier alors pratiquement tout m'a
échappé ben je tournais un point assez
remarquable d'habitude la plus ce qui
vous échappent principalement pendant
qu'on tourne c'est le film ça déjà
puisque on ignore alors là ça m'a encore
plus échapper que d'habitude ça c'est le
grand talent daïra sac souci c'est de
gérard enfin un film qui est en dit
autant sans jamais rien dire finalement
on va garder en soi un petit extrait de
francky ce très beau film d'arras accès
c'est la tradition ici c'est vous qui
commentait alors on y voit une scène de
vous avec jérémie rénier qui joue votre
fils donc comment est-ce que c'est
tourner la scène que vous dis à grassac
ce qu'est ce qui se joue pour vous à ce
moment-là peut-être avec le comédien que
jérémie rénier on regarde nos malheureux
oh oui bien sûr véronique paul c'est la
peine qui doit se plaint amos et moi
j'en connais pas que ces vacances elles
sont loin d'être idyllique il vous parle
hairaz non pas du tout sur sept sur
scène mais ma vie nous a très peu parlé
une fois qu'il m'a dit soit pas ironique
on
quand je veux pas que tu le choix c'est
pratiquement la seule chose qui m'a dit
mais c'était important cela quand même
beaucoup déterminer tout le déroulé du
film veut dire qu'il suffit d'un mot en
fait une intention oui parce qu'il
disait en disant ça il a dit beaucoup de
choses et puis avait un autre moment
dans une scène dans la première scène à
la piscine aussi là aussi trouvé qu'il y
avait une petite en phase qui lui
plaisait pas et avec ses deux petites
choses il m'a fait comprendre énormément
de choses sur ce qu'ils voulaient en
tous les cas voilà c'est à dire qu'il
voulait que ce soit une actrice qui
ressemble pas à une actrice finalement
c'est à dire on est toujours plus
actrice qu'on ne croie ou qu'on souhaite
parfois c'est très curieux et lui
voulaient rien de tout ça il voulait à
degré zéro du jeu moi ça m'a rappelé la
manière dont j'ai joué dans les films de
godard
oui ça va beaucoup rappelé que je
faisais dans sauve qui peut et un peu
dans passion pourquoi et bien sûr ça sur
ceux sur cette capacité tout d'un coup
qu'à un metteur en scène a tiré de son
acteur ou de son actrice une une extrême
simplicité qui donne vraiment le
sentiment qu'on fait rien du tout je me
demandais parfois ça je me demandais pas
je lui fais entièrement confiance mais
j'avais c'était vraiment de tout repos
pour moi j'avais besoin de nouveaux
tours de serre troïka et non mais
finalement même quand on pas en faire
très peu mais on en fait toujours trop
c'est vrai pour ce film là en tous les
cas pas pour un autre film est pour pour
ce film là pour ce qu'il attendait
c'était déjà trop le fait de jouer en
anglais ça change quelque chose excuses
et d'amateurisme nom n'est pas tout à
fait la même personne quand on joue en
anglais là c'est bien parce que je joue
en anglais quand je joue avec mon mari
qui anglais ou irlandais parce que c'est
brendan gleeson qui fait le roule je
joue en français quand je joue avec mon
fils la langue anglaise est là sa
musique est là une manière on prononce
pas les choses de la même manière le
visage je pas par elle est à bout je
bouge pas pareil on n'est pas la même
personne quand on parle dans une autre
planche vous sauviez de tous vos
personnages
oui plus ou moins quand même
enfin je me souviens plus des
circonstances dans lesquelles les films
étaient tony salamé la mémoire des
acteurs c'est curieux aussi on se
souvient oui enfin je n'ai pas la même
mémoire d'actrice et de spectatrice bien
sûr il ya des roms en particulier qui
vous ont marqués qui nous ont suivis
très longtemps
aucun ah c'est pas vrai ok ça veut dire
que vous avez la capacité d'oublier tout
de suite c'est qu'ils ont suivi les
autres mais moi ils m'ont passé les
joyaux
oui il reste dans la mémoire des gens
mais reste cependant la mienne un peu du
jour à vivre avec le personnage pendant
deux trois ans mais d'abord il n'y a pas
assez de place du temps s'ouvre il ya
une phrase qui revenait à votre propos
mondiale a peur de rien vous là vous
prenez cette phrase moi j'ai perdu tout
donc
j'ai peur d'eux j'ai pas peur de choses
qui ne m'ont pas qu'ils sont pas
vraiment dangereux surtout franchement
si aucun danger à faire ce que je fais
le mac os toujours pour michael haneke
surtout quand on joue pour michael
haneke bien sûr parce que vous on est on
est dans des situations d'extrême
confort au contraire balade dans mon cas
moi je de jeu
je prends strictement aucun risque pour
vous avez peur de tout parce que je sais
c'est de tout donc je suis de beaucoup
de choses oui bon ça vous est jamais
arrivé d'avoir perçu un film non parce
que j'ai eu la chance justement que tous
les que toutes les commandes ya là dans
un film il faut qu'il y ait de la
confiance et faux billets de la croyance
il faut qu'il y ait beaucoup de choses
et la plupart des films que j'ai faits
il y avait ça il y avait la confiance
vers la croyance y avait il y avait tout
ce qui requiert la laventure du film et
ça ça repose sur mettant en scène sur un
réalisateur et un directeur d'acteurs
essentiellement sur le metteur en scène
bien sûr c'est que c'est que bien sûr
c'est que quelque chose qui se passe
entre le mettant en scène et essoyes ces
rapports particuliers aussi qu'on a avec
un médecin qu'il soit directif pour être
justement en tant que comédien ou
comédienne dans ce pays il a dit qu'un
chemin mais il ya beaucoup de manières
d'indiquer un chemin c'est pas forcément
de le diriger mais indiquer un chemin
c'est c'est juste une manière d'être une
manière de vous regarder une manière de
ses concerts vous savez en ce moment je
travaille avec bob wilson et bob wilson
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui indique à
chaud mais alors et c'est pour moi c'est
un
immense le temps c'est un immense
metteur en scène j'ai même du mal à le
qualifier de mai dans tes c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui crée un monde est qui et
qui justement par sa manière de faire
vous vous indique que justement indiqué
à chopin c'est évidemment pas diriger
c'est évidemment par 10 h au cccc vous
l'indiquez du voilà de la manière la
plus la plus politique la plus sincère
yale parfois la plus abstraite ou si
c'est tout à fait extraordinaire et ça
vous arrive d'être insatisfaite face
justement à ces exigences de metteur en
scène que vous admirez manifestement non
à ses assesseurs votre travail vous non
non mais c'est maintenant au tour de la
session non non non ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas parce qu'on est con on est
satisfait qu'on est sûr de soi
et pourtant c'est mon cas j'ai travaillé
quand même le métier d'acteur
[Musique]
c'est aussi un travail mais c'est un
état aussi c'est un certain rapport au
monde c'est beaucoup de choses
mais c'est moi un travail par exemple
que si vous prenez on va dire des
cousins très proche qui serait le
chanteur et de danseur c'est un peu ce
qu'ils sont le plus proches de l'acteur
en en étant très très très très loin qui
eux justement pas ça passe par un
travail très très repérable l'acteur
s'est pas vraiment un travail c'est le
travail comme ça c'est dans cet état que
moi est ce que vous le définiriez
justement puisque c'est au tour de sa
con con qu'on tourne depuis le début de
cet entretien
oh c'est un état particulier comme un
aveugle qui avancerait voilà c'est un
peu il ya un peu ces images là qui me
viennent quand je pense à moi actrice on
a peu à la foi aveugle et clairvoyant
c'est un salaire ben j'ai rappelé en
début d'émission et cinéaste
extraordinaire avec qui vous avez tourné
ça vous arrive de de dire un cinéaste
j'ai envie de travailler avec vous ou
avec toi oui ça m'est arrivé souvent ça
m'est arrivé pour lady ailleurs en saxe
parce que vous avez vu c'est une
précédent oui j'ai vu la vie citoyenne
j'ai vu
problème il est chez quelqu'un enfin il
paraît que c'est dans le dossier de
presse je me suis dit fais les jolis
lots de cette place parce que je
n'arrive pas à me souvenir comment nous
étions rencontrés
je pense que c'est une rencontre qui
était provoquée par mois mais je me suis
appuyé en fait je vous écris je
apparemment je les écris hamel c'est
commode les essais presse aux airs de
kiwi samassa me rappeler la mémoire
après on s'est rencontrés s'est jamais
violent ce métier si ça peut l'être mais
mais papa là où ça se passe c'est
violent là où cela se passe pas toujours
bien là quand ça se passe passe est
violent mais quand ça se passe c'est
jamais bien pour moi non ou alors dehors
oui enfin quand je dis là où ça se passe
là je regarde la caméra pour l'acteur
c'est cela que ça se passe
et là c'est jamais lieu landre camara
j'aime bien ton nom
non enfin le fait d'être deux noms le
fou de jouer vous ne cessez jamais
violent même si c'est toujours un acte
libérateur un acte osséja
c'est pas violent même quand ça laisse à
l'époque c'est la rsx comment est ce que
voulait définir et non celle d'avatar ça
que c'est les aléas et les voilà sa
violence aussi parce que c'est pas assez
si vous regardez bien filmée je suis sûr
que voilà il est regardé de collet sait
pas très bien mais pas suffisamment pour
savoir que vous avez évidemment saisi
qui a à la fois de la delà de la douceur
il ya de la vie beaucoup une certaine
une certaine violence je dirais pas
beaucoup de violence dans le film mais
un film qui parle à ce point là d'un
trajet de vide d'une vie qui va
s'arrêter de 2,2 de compte qu'on règle
un petit peu parce qu'il ya ça aussi et
des comptes au sens propre du mot parce
que c'est une partie de la relation
qu'elle a avec son fils
donc elle la violence quand même dans sa
iap à cause de la douceur sinon il n'y
aurait pas de quoi en faire un film et
c'est ma dernière question qu'il y ait
finalement pas beaucoup de différence
entre celles que vous êtes et l'actrice
que vous êtes
isabelle huppert dans le cadre de votre
métier c'est à dire que parfois le
cinéma puis vous aider
vous apprendre vous enseigner des choses
pour être celle que vous êtes non il m'a
rien enseigné
non il m'a me fait vivre chez capcom
c'est par ci un film il avait francky
d'arras axa a été présenté lundi en
compétition vous y interpréter isabelle
huppert le rôle titre on l'a compris aux
côtés de marisa tomei greg kinnear
jérémie rénier est passé à l' grégory on
vous souhaite évidemment de le retrouver
au palmarès ne sera là pour la sortie on
en parlera évidemment d'autant que la
sortie c'est le 28 août le jour de la
sainte augustin merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir suivi cet entretien tout de
suite la suite